when you're starting something new right  it can be very nebulous right especially  if you have a technology but the theme  of facial recognition if there was a  theme to it it's about safety and  security right you can unlock your phone  with facial recognition  id checks are done with facial  recognition these are all things done in  an opt-in way and then you also have  something like clear view which can be  also for safety which is searching a  database  to identify someone who's unknown  right so we're always thinking about  safety and security we never even though  i spent my  earlier part of my career doing consumer  internet we couldn't really think of a  use case there